cette année pourquoi ne pas mettre de
côté le vinaigre et le citron pour la
dégustation des huîtres le conseil du
professionnel la meilleure façon c'est
justement un chef étoilé qui nous
l'avait conseillé s'est rajouté du
poivre blanc donc foire aux plantes du
pendjab un tour de moulin à poivre ça va
justement équilibré lui puisque lui de
ses salles et naturellement donc le
poivre à côté val justement donner un
bel équilibre et sa complète très bien
huîtres c'est beaucoup plus intéressant
que le citron l'agneau men to rain sera
peut-être sur vos tables jérôme bouchet
sous les halles de tours opte pour un
gigot avec un four à 180° et là on va
être sur 1 heure un quart une heure et
demie souvent la grosseur du gigot parce
que cela peut varier de 2 kg 2 kg 2 à 3
kg 2 voire plus on le met au four on n'y
touche plus on la rose à la rigueur une
fois on prend un petit peu de jus mais
c'est tout on peut être avec les invités
sans problème la volaille fait aussi
partie des fêtes en touraine l'une des
stars c'est la poulette de racan une
poule blanche aux pattes bleues avec une
chair ferme qui se rapprochent juste
hâtivement que la pintade michael
volaille et nous livre sa recette vous
l'avez fait à la cocotte de fer pur 1h15
une petite heure et demie tranquillement
vous allez la remettre dans la cocotte
et qui vous allez mettre des petits prix
ou les abricots
et après vous pouvez dégâts c'est avec
un petit peu de cidre en fin de cuisson
ça ça peut être très bien côté fromages
la région centre et le pays de la chèvre
sainte-maure selles sur cher chavignol
aux poulies ni la biquette sera bien
dans nos assiettes mais attention un
fromage ne se déguste pas juste à sa
sortie du réfrigérateur
c'est pas qu'il va perdre le soffons
dans ce décorum on va perdre et des
saveurs gustatives surtout war l'idéal
si vous avez un cellier ou même un
garage ou le fromage est stocké à 12
degrés 15 degrés ça va très bien et vous
le ramenez une heure avant et tu vas
prendre la température serait très bien
et pour le dessert vous pouvez rester
sur du local biscuit noisette crème
vanille pomme caramélisée la bûche
tourangelle saura ravir vos invités